[Music]
and II know it was the independent
journalist in the Pacific Northwest has
been on the show a number of times he
covers in Tifa quite a bit he was at an
NT for a li over the weekend minding his
own business covering the news he's a
journalist when he was beaten almost to
death by an Tifa went up in the hospital
he just got out and joins us now on this
program we're happy to see Andy I'm glad
you're capable of doing this interview
tell us what happened on Saturday
documenting this protest that was
organized by antiphon its allies we were
a literal stone's throw away from
Portland's most important institutions
of the rule of law the courthouses the
sheriff's office the central police
precinct while hearing people chant no
hate no fear I'm suddenly bashed on the
back of my head from behind and from
there I've I'm a very possible person
I've never been in a fight it took me a
few seconds to realize that I was
actually even hit in my head when I
realized what was happening and was too
late a mob of people all dressed in
black and wearing masks started beating
me with their fists and some of them use
objects to hit me I don't know how many
people were involved it seemed like five
ten fifteen or twenty it could have been
that many they beat me so much that I
lost control of my GoPro camera that I
was holding which was then stolen from
me and when I thought it was over I was
wrong I put my arms up to try to shield
my face as well as to signal to them
that I was surrendering and that I
wasn't there to fight but that really
signaled to them to be more aggressive
so then they started dumping what I
believe were milkshakes and eggs
throwing it out my face which blinded me
so I couldn't see and I was
kick some more punch some more and all
this time I kept thinking we're the
police
I could still see the Mahnomen County
Justice Center in front of me but no
police have arrived I eventually
stumbled away leading across the park
and I lost my balance so I sat down on
the ground in front of the courthouse
and from there a medic SWAT team
informed me that in order to get an
ambulance to be taken to a hospital I
would have to walk to the police
precinct in other words walk back in the
direction of the demonstrators who just
attacked me later that night after
arriving in the emergency room I had a
CT scan which confirmed that there that
I was diagnosed with a brain hemorrhage
from which you're suffering neurological
damage just to remind our viewers this
is the group that CNN's primetime
anchors have defended and promoted I saw
that Andrew yang who's running for
president as a Democrat bless him
attacked nt for this have you received
any other support very quickly from any
other democratic office holders in
Portland or nationally not that I know
of not that I know of
what that tells you everything and you
know we're happy that you're at least
capable of joining us tonight that's a
shocking story in enraging story we wish
you the best on your recovery we hope
you'll come back thank you thank you